senator Ed Markey of Massachusetts is
demanding answers from the travel
insurance industry this morning a report
from his office warns that consumers
might not get the protection they think
they've paid for consumers spent nearly
three billion dollars on travel
insurance in 2016 it's more than doubled
since 2006 Chris Van Cleve is at Reagan
National Airport outside Washington with
the warnings about the fine print Chris
good morning good morning senator Markey
is sending these letters to two insurers
today this as new research from triple-a
finds as many as forty percent of
Americans are likely to buy travel
insurance for an international trip the
number one reason is cancellation
protection now travel insurance can
cover the cost of a trip if you're
suddenly too sick to fly if you lose
your job if you get injured while you're
traveling you can even kick in money if
a bag is lost but it does not cover
everything I could just feel my blood
boiling
Laura Travian oh spent nearly $1,100 on
flights to Europe for her and her
husband Matt a Marine veteran who did
tours in Iraq and Afghanistan to
celebrate their second anniversary with
the trip ten months away she bought
travel insurance through the airline I
just had a feeling that this time we'd
need it and it wasn't that expensive you
booked the trip you've got this great
plan what happens so about a month after
we booked the trip I find out that I'm
pregnant with my daughter and she's due
October 21st and our flight to come back
from Europe was October 19th so
naturally you can't fly when you're that
pregnant while the insurance covered
illness it did not cover pregnancy her
claim was denied
the only thing skimpier then airplane
legroom is the coverage of these
insurance policies a review by Senator
Edie Marquis office found nearly all
major US airlines and online booking
sites sell travel insurance typically
requiring customers to click yes or no
to purchasing before being allowed to
book a trip the report found what it
calls questionable travel insurance
marketing practices for policies that
offer minimal coverage and often erect
hurdles to the payment of claims
consumers are being tipped upside down
money is shaken out of their pockets and
it's split between the airlines and the
surance companies and it's just plain
wrong just two companies underwrite all
those policies in a statement the US
Travel Insurance Association said the
industry was not contacted by Senator
Markey adding travel insurance is a
valuable product that protects consumers
financial investment the group
recommends that travelers fully
understand the coverage options they are
purchasing to make sure it fits their
needs the purchase of travel insurance
is voluntary the Better Business Bureau
says complaints are on the rise on pace
to exceed 700 this year more than double
the 342 in 2015 you don't even know what
you're getting sometimes Chris Elliot
runs a consumer advocacy website that
tracks the travel industry the solution
is better disclosure by the travel
insurance companies by the airlines and
online travel agencies who are selling
these products and the solution
ultimately is a more informed consumer
by which I mean people actually reading
the fine print for Laura and Matt the
airline refunded the taxes on their
canceled trip but they were out more
than 700 bucks when you come up to that
travel insurance box now what do you do
ignore it you click no mm-hmm nope no
thank you
I'd be out the money anyway and the
report found that often similarly priced
travel insurance plans not offered by
the airlines or those third-party
booking sites provided better coverage
so we reached out to Norwegian the
airline that Laura was flying it tells
us the airline believes its cancellation
and trip protection policies are clear
and were properly followed in this case
but is going to offer a one-time
courtesy refund to Laura for the
remainder of her airfare biana
oh well that's good news for Laura we've
been talking about this this morning I
was a bit conflicted about this story
but I'm not going to defend but you know
it is a talk that's for sure that's for
sure everybody's had this experience
yeah I'm pregnant
[Laughter]
no having a tough travel experience
together in the next hour
Don we'll discuss getting pregnant
yes I'm insuring against that